perianism
three years ago vladimir putin said that
western liberalism was dead
last year president xi
argued that the west is declining
in april 2022
things look very different
recent months have shown the deep
resilience of the human spirit
and of free societies
faced with appalling barbarism and war
crimes which we'd hoped had been
confined to history
the free world has united behind ukraine
in its brave fight for freedom and
self-determination
those who think they can win through
oppression coercion or invasion are
being proved wrong by this new stand on
global security
one not not only seeks to deter
but also ensures that aggressors fail
we can't be complacent the fate of
ukraine hangs in the balance
but let's be clear
if putin succeeds
there will be untold further misery
across europe
and terrible consequences across the
globe
we would never feel safe again
so we must be prepared for the long haul
we've got to double down on our support
for ukraine
and we must follow through on the unity
that we've shown in the crisis
we must reboot
recast and remodel our approach
my vision
is a world where free nations are
assertive
and in the ascendant where freedom and
democracy are strengthened through a
network of economic and security
partnerships
where aggressors are contained
and forced to take a better path
this is the long-term prize
a new era of peace security and
prosperity
let's be honest
the architecture that was designed to
guarantee peace and prosperity has
failed ukraine
the economic and security structures
that were developed after the second
world war and the cold war have been
bent out of shape so far
they have enabled rather than containing
aggression
russia is able to block any effective
action at the u.n security council
putin sees his veto
as a green light to barbarism
he's walked away from the nato-russia
founding act and the treaty on
conventional armed forces in europe
he's violated multiple measures on arms
control
the g20 can't function as an effective
economic body
while russia remains at the table
the soviet union
used to regularly use their un veto
but for all the many evils that they
inflicted
even they behaved with some kind of
rationality on the world stage they were
able to see stick to deals when they saw
risks to strategic stability
as they did with the anti-ballistic
missile treaty
they would de-escalate when they were
confronted and called out
as with the cuban missile crisis 60
years ago
and they had their eye on their global
reputation
none of these factors apply to putin
we're dealing with a desperate rogue
operator with no interest in
international mores
this is at a time when the world economy
has never been more open to russia
during the cold war western allies
fueled each other's prosperity
and we restricted flows of trade and
investment and technology to the ussr
in the 1990s these constraints were
removed
but it didn't lead to the expected gains
in economic openness and democracy
we took progress for granted instead of
applying the necessary carrots and
sticks
and leaders like putin spun the
opportunity to change because they
feared that they would lose control
instead they took the money from oil and
gas
and they used it to consolidate their
power and to gain leverage abroad
vandal dirk handle
the assumption that economic integration
drives political change did not work
we now need a new approach one that
melds hard security and economic
security one that builds stronger global
alliances and where free nations are
more assertive and self-confident one
that recognizes that geopolitics is back
britain has always stood up to bullies
we've always been risk takers so we are
prepared to be bold
using our strength in security and
diplomacy our economic heft and our will
and agility to lead the way
we're already stepping up in ukraine
the war in ukraine is our war
it's everyone's war because ukraine's
victory is a strategic imperative for
all of us
heavy weapons tanks aeroplanes digging
deep in our inventories ramping up
production
we need to do all of this our sanctions
have already seen russia facing its
first external debt default for a
century and we need to go further
there must be nowhere for putin to fund
this appalling war and that means
cutting off oil and gas imports once and
for all
at the same time we need to deliver
support for the ukrainian people it
means helping refugees it means
delivering food medicine other
essentials and it means keeping the
economy afloat
it also means holding the putin regime
to account
for the appalling crimes that have been
committed
and when the guns finally fall silent in
ukraine
it means making sure kiev has the
resources it needs to maintain security
deter further attacks and rebuild
that's why we're working on a joint
commission with poland to ensure ukraine
is equipped with nato standard weapons
and it's why we're determined to work
with the us with the eu
and other allies on a new marshall plan
for the country
ukraine deserves nothing less than a
landmark international effort to rebuild
their towns and cities regenerate their
industries and secure their freedom for
the long term
we're doubling down
we will keep going further and faster to
push russia out of the whole of ukraine
and this has to be a catalyst for wider
change
we need to apply this tough stance to
the threats that are emerging beyond
ukraine
our approach is based on three areas
military strength
economic security
and deeper global alliances
firstly we need to strengthen our
collective defense
in the words of president zielenski
freedom must be better armed than
tyranny
ahead of the nato summit in madrid we
need to lift our sights
we have long argued that nato needs to
be flexible agile and integrated
the eastern flank must be strengthened
and we must support crucial states like
poland
that's why we're increasing our troop
presence and we're deepening our defense
cooperation
we also have to learn the lessons of
ukraine
the united kingdom sent weapons and
trains ukrainian troops long before the
war started
but the world should have done more to
deter the invasion
and we will never make that same mistake
again
some argue that we shouldn't provide
heavy weapons for fear of provoking
something worse
but my view is that inaction would be
the greatest provocation
this is a time for courage
not for caution
and we must ensure that alongside
ukraine
the western balkans and countries like
moldova and georgia have the resilience
and the capabilities to maintain their
sovereignty and freedom
nato's open door policy is sacrosanct
if finland and sweden choose to join in
response to russia's aggression we must
integrate them as soon as possible
and we reject the false choice between
stronger traditional defense and modern
capabilities
we need to defend ourselves against
attacks in space and cyberspace
as well as by land air and sea
we also reject the false choice
between euro atlantic security
and indo-pacific security
in the modern world we need both
we need a global nato
by that i don't mean extending the
membership to those from other regions
i mean that nato must have a global
outlook ready to tackle global threats
we need to preempt threats in the
indo-pacific
working with our allies like japan and
australia to ensure the pacific is
protected
and we must ensure that democracies like
taiwan
are able to defend themselves
all of this will require resources
we're correcting a generation of under
investment and that's why the prime
minister has announced the biggest
investment in our armed forces since the
cold war
we recognize russia as the most acute
threat in our integrated review
adopting the same vigilance as nato's
eastern allies
others are now stepping up as well but
we all need to go further
spending two percent on defense
must be a floor
not a ceiling
there is no substitute for hard military
power
backed by intelligence and diplomacy
secondly we need to recognize the
growing role the economy plays in
security
in the uk we're now using all of our
economic levers trade sanctions
investment and development policy in a
much more assertive way
we recognize that growth from cheap gas
and money siphoned from kleptocracies
is growth built on sand
it's not the same as real sustained
growth from higher productivity and
greater innovation
free trade and free markets are the most
powerful engine of human progress
we will always champion economic freedom
but free trade must be fair and that
means playing by the rules
for too long many have been naive about
the geopolitical power of economics
aggressors treat it as a tool of foreign
policy
using patronage investment and debt as a
means to exert control and coerce
they're ruthless in their approach
our response won't mirror their malign
tactics but we will match them in our
resolve
it's time to wise up access to the
global economy must depend on playing by
the rules and there can be no more free
passes
we're showing this in the russia ukraine
conflict russia's past has been
rescinded
we're hitting them with every element of
economic policy we've raised tariffs on
russian goods we've cut them off from
wto terms we've banned their ships from
our ports we've banned their planes from
our airports we have sanctioned in the
united kingdom
more individuals and organizations than
any other nation hitting russia's banks
oligarchs defense companies central bank
reserves and oil and gas supplies
we are cutting off the funding for
putin's war effort
we're also cutting investment ties with
russia
banning all new outward investments and
ending the investor visa
at the same time we're removing all
import tariffs for ukraine and we're
supporting the ukrainian economy with
loan guarantees fiscal support and
investment
we are showing that economic access is
no longer a given it has to be earned
countries must play by the rules and
that includes china
beijing has not condemned russian
aggression or its war crimes
russian exports to china rose by almost
a third in the first quarter of this
year
they've sought to coerce lithuania
they're commenting on who should or
shouldn't be
a member of nato
and they're rapidly building a military
capable of projecting power deep into
areas of european strategic interest
but china is not impervious
by talking about the rise of china as
inevitable
we are doing china's work for it
in fact their rise isn't inevitable
they will not to continue to rise if
they don't play by the rules
china needs trade with the g7
we represent half of the global economy
and we have choices
we've shown with russia the kind of
choices we're prepared to make when
international rules are violated
and we've shown that we're prepared to
prioritize security
and respect for sovereignty over
short-term economic gain
not least because we know that the cost
of not acting is higher
the fact is that most of the world does
respect sovereignty
it's only a few pariahs and outliers
that don't
so we're working more closely with our
allies and friends old and new
and the same assertive approach that can
constrain our rivals can be a powerful
driver of prosperity and security
that's why we're building new trade
links including work on free trade
agreements with countries like india
indonesia we're joining the cptpp
we're sharing our expertise in science
and tech signing new partnerships around
the world
and we're providing a better offer on
development with investment to
low-income countries
that comes without malign strings
attached
by being tough and united
by working together and expanding trade
we can deprive aggressors of their
leverage and we can reduce strategic
dependence
and we can help each other to weather
the storm
of soaring food and energy prices
at the world bank last week we secured
170 billion dollars to help low-income
countries deal with these challenges
and we're getting ahead in other
possible areas of strategic dependence
whether it's minerals or rare earth
metals we're joining forces to prevent
future problems before they emerge
this is how we will strengthen
our shared economic security
that brings me on to the final point
which is that our prosperity and
security must be built on a network of
strong partnerships
this is what i've described as the
network of liberty
the fundamental principle
is that no matter the challenges we
should not turn inward and pursue
autarky
we should reach out and embrace new
partnerships
what the dutch and others have called
open autonomy
in a world where malign actors are
trying to undermine multilateral
institutions
we know that bilateral and plural actual
groups will play a greater role
partnerships like the nato like the g7
and the commonwealth are vital
and we should keep strengthening our
nato alliance with bonds around the
world
like the uk led joint expeditionary
force the five eyes and the orcas
partnership that we have with united
states and australia
and we want to keep growing our ties
with countries like japan
india and indonesia
we also should build on the strong core
that we have in the g7
during the uk's presidency last year i
was pleased to bring friends like
australia korea india south africa and
asean to the table
the g7 should act as an economic nato
collectively defending our prosperity
if the economy of a partner is being
targeted by an aggressive regime we
should act to support them
all for one and one for all
and to the 141 countries from all
continents who voted to condemn russia's
action at the un
i hear your voice
i share your outrage at russia's illegal
war
and i share your fundamental belief
in sovereignty in fair play and the rule
of law
so let's work together
let's forge deeper bonds let's be better
traders investors and partners than the
aggressors
the uk is prepared to do things
differently we're prepared to think
differently and we're prepared to work
differently with you to get things done
there is huge strengths in collective
action
and let me be clear this also applies to
alliances that the uk is not part of
we support the indo-pacific quad
we support an outward-looking eu and
we're working closely together on
ukraine
we support asean the african union and
the u.s mexico canada trade agreement
we reject the old ideas of hierarchical
systems exclusive groups and spheres of
influence
we want to see a network of partnerships
stretching around the world standing up
for sovereignty and self-determination
and building shared prosperity and the
uk
will be an active and agile part of this
network
actually excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
geopolitics is back
after the cold war
we all thought that peace stability and
prosperity would spread inexorably
around the globe
we thought that we learnt the lessons of
history and the march of progress would
continue unchallenged
we were wrong
but this is no council of despair
in the face of rising aggression we do
have the power to act and we need to act
now
we must be assertive
aggressors are looking at what has
happened in ukraine and we need to make
sure that they get the right message
together we have tremendous strength
let's use it to forge a better more
secure world and a stronger global
economy
this will take the energies of all of
the people in this room and beyond
it will be hard
but we have to step up and take
responsibility
the aggressors are prepared to be bold
we must be bolder
that is how we will ensure that
ukraine's sovereignty is restored
that is how we will ensure
that aggression and coercion fail
and that is how
across the globe
we will win this new era for peace
security and prosperity
thank you
now ladies and gentlemen i invite you to
join me in a toast to thank our host for
this evening
the lord mayor and the lady may arrest
[Applause]
you